hello my amiga borer amigo doesn't
matter what gender you are you're my
friend regardless Gregory
Lisa Lisa mihalick Malik mihalick Nick
Jonas is one of Lisa's favorite actors
the star of this movie called goat that
is getting a lot of press right now
people really into it dude
so I'm telling you we're gonna probably
watch this trailer right now
goat great title already intrigued yeah
I love goat so personal thing for me
goats I used to own several goats well
they released a lot of oxytocin which
greatest strong bond for them but was
horrible when I had to kill them to eat
them for Thanksgiving oh wow
this movie's rated R for disturbing
behavior involving hazing Lisa knows the
college days as do I strong sexual
content and nudity Nick Jonas huh
pervasive language of violence alcohol
abuse and some drug use much you know
when I hear the word goat yeah that is
pretty much the imagery that comes to
mind okay it's a song about college kids
or something amazing hazing I think on
the rush in Nepal
these are the best you know you're gonna
be here drink Wow wrong we not the weak
ones oh man this pledge getting weirder
pledges gotta go through these quit it
be clip there's another guy that
shouldn't happen
I'm getting sex for the first time in my
life I'm stupid because I
but we haven't been doing anything that
every other fraternity on campus hasn't
been doing
that's my birthday September 23rd okay
sorry so why'd you share a birthday with
that movie yeah is awesome because I've
seen so many movies that are about like
their comedies or goofy comedies about
you know being a fraternity having their
pledges like that look no and that's my
point is this is like a dark realistic
approach you some types of like pledges
that happen as I have thought that
before like this seems really abusive do
people ever really have to go through
this and the way they were shooting it
looked like a documentary
yeah it did which is really really that
was really uncomfortable I was thinking
like why would they want to be in
something that they have to do all that
you know like you know it's like to be a
guy in college I do I have been I've
been so many fraternities haha oh I was
in a sorority I didn't have to do any of
that
you didn't mm-hmm I've heard crazy
sorority stories I knew a girl who had a
cousin whose cousin went to a school
where there a sorority that she was a
part of I you know give head to guys in
order to get it thanks ray let's make
that up no I did it I'm serious that's
why I came up with that whole like
connection because I was thinking about
all the people not something I made that
up Lisa that is crazy
a goat goats yeah man does he gotta keep
them in check or something because goats
herd together
I heard heard I heard they herd together
what are some of the things they were
doing in here
push-ups I hate doing push-ups man
alcohol of you
indeed it's a spit on that was gross
eating hot that was that hot dog yeah
therefore seat hot dog I mean that's not
bad yeah you know you just asked for
some breath and I might have make it a
little better my god soggy but who
really cares yeah this is like an animal
house meets Full Metal Jacket that was a
perfect description of this it makes me
uncomfortable because I had to go
through that you really did I really did
I was part of Kappas Katie K Kappa I was
in a sorority and we definitely we
didn't have to do all that was everyone
who want me no and that's not a real
sorority then I know my facts and the
real sororities which are roughly about
only 46% of sororities are actual real
sororities are primarily lesbians
interesting this is really about me
sharing my statistical knowledge right
yes it has a 66 percent on Rotten
Tomatoes oh I was gonna be like
something like that at first cuz you
know college movie it just like brought
me back to that and then I like twisting
I like the darkness I do too because I
thought it was just gonna be kind of no
offense but like kind of like a typical
typical just like oh I can protect that
I bet there are some real horror stories
to be part of a fraternity oh yeah I
mean I have heard stories I'm just
saying that I don't know the school I
went to we did it one time I had to you
know get into my kappa kk kappa k kappa
i had to poop off the freeway okay
I did while I was blindfolded with my
hands behind my back taped with rope
around my ankles did everybody I was the
one who volunteered they said I would
get into the fraternity faster uh-huh
and what made you want to be in that
fraternity that made that okay I wanted
to be accepted I felt that in order to
be a real man I had to be put these were
the coolest guys in school they were the
most respected and I wanted to leave
behind my reputation in life I was the
first one in Alba generation ever there
having been heard of a college okay you
know first one hundreds of Alba's first
one okay well thanks for sharing that
that was very deep and personal thank
you Lisa
you're welcome we're here for you I like
gene thank you see this button here if
you click it you subscribe it's a good
thing subscription services exist
I have many that I have tried to
discontinue but by keeping my card on
file
occasionally my PayPal it becomes rather
difficult process to cancel but if you
don't want to subscribe to us anymore
just a little button you gotta press
Lisa is that's what I promote for you
you used to yeah what I promote now
Lisa's on Instagram oh you remember the
cat is pooping in there freeway callback
we learned that in our acting classes
yeah how to do comedy that repetitive
so repetitive yeah it's back and forth
back and forth it's don't try to
outshine your partner work with your
partner always say yes always say yes it
wasn't yes it was off the freeway if he
said no it's not funny and that's why I
never did not you're welcome we just
taught you what one where how very
simple questions